Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir machen heute Salon. Ja. Wir sind angekündigt zu spät.
Ja.
Wir hatten ja gesagt am 18.
Wir hatten aber auch sehr viel zu lesen, nämlich zwei dicke Bücher.
Die liegen hier.
Über Open AI und Sam Oldman und nicht nur Sam Oldman, sondern natürlich auch alles, was da so dranhängt an Ideologie, an Kolonialismus. Bevor wir dazu kommen, wollen wir erst darauf hinweisen, dass wir jetzt am 23. August live zu erleben sind in Frankfurt. Wir werden also einen Live-Podcast auf großer Bühne machen.
Wir packen uns Politiker.
Ich bin gespannt, was du davor hast.
Wir beantworten eure Fragen.
Und ich bringe auch was mit, aber ich will es noch nicht verraten, was ich mitbringe. Jedenfalls gibt es noch Karten.
Das heißt, ich weiß es auch noch nicht.
Der Link steht in der Beschreibung. Jetzt werden natürlich gerade am heutigen Tag viele sagen, wie ordnen Stefan und Wolfgang das geopolitisch und geökonomisch alles ein? Und natürlich müssen wir uns auch zu dieser Sache äußern. Die Rede ist natürlich von Labubus. Ist das für dich ein Phänomen, wo du sagst, da musst du...
Und wenn ihr bei Steady seid, wir würden uns auch freuen, wenn ihr ein Jahresabobuch abschließt. Also ihr könntet das monatsweise buchen. Kein Problem. Besser ist es, wenn ihr ein Jahresabobuch abschließt. Erstmal ist es etwas günstiger. Und es ist auch besser für uns, denn wir haben gesehen, diese ganzen Zahlungsdienstleister nehmen von...
Die passieren jedes Mal mit, wenn eine Zahlung ausglückt.
Ja, und von Monat zu Monat mehr. Also es ist wirklich obskur. Und da hängt natürlich auch am Ende hier, der oft erwähnte in den Büchern, Peter Thiel dahinter.
Ja, und Borgman, der hat ja bei Stripe gearbeitet.
Stripe, PayPal, also diese ganze Geschichte, alles geht da immer noch so mit. Insofern ein Jahresabobuch vermeidet zumindest, dass sie jedes Mal noch mal Zugriff haben und gibt uns auch ein bisschen Kontinuität. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns gleich im Salon wiedersehen. Bis dahin.
Bis gleich.